let's go next to our collar let's go to
the 408 area code caller from 408 what's
your name where you're calling from hi
this is Logan from San Jose hey Logan
what's up I actually have another
question on voter turnout so with the
you know all the coronavirus
restrictions in and the social
distancing I'm hoping that stuff gets
you know a lot of it gets cleared up by
November but I think the the
after-effects of it are going to last
longer you know people aren't going to
go out as much and you know I'm just
wondering I think there is going to be a
lower turbo turnout in November but do
you think that's good you know
historically a lower vertical owner
turnout disproportionately hurts
Democrats but do you think that's going
to be the case or is it going to be more
of an across-the-board lower turnout you
know if you put a gun to my head and say
you've got a bet on it my bet is that
the virus will impact voter turnout in
November in a way that helps Trump and
the reason why I say that is Democrats
are taking the virus much more seriously
than Republicans Democrats are social
distancing much more than Republicans so
no matter what happens my instinct is
there will be more Democrats who opted
not to go out in public and a large
crowd at voting locations then
Republicans who will do that so I
believe that the voter turnout dynamics
in November are going to be beneficial
to Donald Trump I want to be wrong and
we need to work to make that not be the
case I think we should go to 100%
absentee ballot voting by mail but I
think if we just have a normal everybody
shows up to vote on November 6th I think
it helps Trump right right and you know
it was obviously unprecedented so it's
pretty hard to predict kind of shot in
the dark there yeah all we can look at
is taking the social distancing more
seriously and that's what makes me think
that okay well one other quick question
on well I've been thinking a little bit
more about why Bernie didn't do so well
in the in the primary and I know I
listened to some of your commentary
saying that you know the progressive
platform isn't necessarily as popular
Reddit and Twitter would make you
believe and that's you know being young
that's right I do spend a lot of my time
so I was a little disappointed there but
my question is you know moving forward
maybe just the next election do you
think it would be beneficial for a
progressive candidate to kind of hone in
focus on on one piece of the platform
and and naturally that would be Medicare
for all because I think that's the most
popular and present a more I guess
moderate stance on some of the other
progressive topics I don't know that I
would say I don't know that it's about
being more moderate in some areas and
more progressive in other areas I think
it's just about the framing and PR
around the campaign you can be
progressive in five important areas but
there is strategy understanding you
where you were running and your
constituents to know which one is more
important so let me give you an example
if you're in a very very heavy Union
area with manufacturing for example I
don't fall for this stuff of everybody
loves their health plan but it is true
that there are lots of unionized workers
who are satisfied with the health care
that they have because they've done
collective bargaining and they have
something way better than what lots of
other people have in a place like that
you might want to focus more on maybe
its minimum wage
maybe it's workers rights maybe it's
education rather than maybe Medicare for
all because you understand your
constituency where it is less of an
issue for them to go to Medicare for all
because they like what their union may
have been able to negotiate for them
that doesn't mean you change your
position on Medicare for all it just
means that maybe in your district you
campaign a little differently does that
make sense yeah yeah so you just you
kind of tailor the message to ever the
audiences right exactly exactly doesn't
mean you compromise on your values or
your positions but the focus of your
campaign may be affected okay um I got
for you today I appreciate you taking my
call alright thank you I appreciate you
calling in great to hear from you